A quanti di voi è mai capitato di
osservare il cielo notturno magari in un
posto molto buio isolato
Beh per quelli che non l'hanno mai fatto
Credetemi sulla parola quello che si
presenta ai nostri occhi è uno
spettacolo che ci lascia senza fiato
magari qualcuno di voi avrà osservato il
cielo con l'ausilio di un telescopio o
anche un semplice binocolo e avrà
scoperto che ci sono delle stelle che
non arrivano ai nostri occhi ad occhio
nudo non riusciamo a vederle
Io ricordo ancora la prima volta che mi
sono trovata in un osservatorio
astrofisico proprio qui alle isole
Canarie e ho potuto osservare il cielo
in uno dei posti più bui del mondo non
riuscivo a credere ai miei occhi perché
c'erano così tante stelle
Eppure la luce a cui i nostri occhi sono
sensibili non è che una piccola parte di
tutto quello che costantemente ci arriva
dal nostro universo
la luce visibile che noi oggi sappiamo è
un'onda elettromagnetica non è che una
piccola parte di qualcosa di molto più
ampio chiamato spettro elettromagnetico
Lo spettro elettromagnetico è l'insieme
di tutte le onde elettromagnetiche di
tutte le frequenze di tutte le lunghezze
d'onda a queste grandezze frequenza e
lunghezza d'onda e poi Associata a una
terza grandezza chiamata energia per cui
spesso gli astrofisici parlano per
descrivere le componenti dello spettro
elettromagnetico in termini di energia
del fotone che è il quanto di luce
Ebbene lo sviluppo tecnologico dello
scorso secolo ci ha consentito di andare
a studiare l'universo in tutte le sue
frequenze in tutti i suoi colori per
andare a osservare qualcosa che ai
nostri occhi è nascosto
per cui quando osserviamo l'universo
nelle diverse frequenze osserviamo cose
diverse riceviamo messaggi complementari
è quello che nel visibile ci appare
calmo tranquillo quasi immutato Alle
alte alle altre energie in particolare
alle energie dei raggi gamma che sono la
componente più energetica dello spettro
elettromagnetico l'universo appare
rapidamente variabile estremamente
violento Ma di che energia stiamo
parlando
senza mettere numeri particolari
Dobbiamo capire che le energie i raggi
gamma hanno energie che vanno dai
milioni alle migliaia di miliardi di
volte L'energia della luce visibile
Dove vengono prodotti questi raggi gamma
così energetici così violenti Vengono
prodotti in ambienti come esplosioni di
stelle fusioni di stelle di neutroni o
da dei getti di materia che vengono
espulsi quasi alla velocità della luce
in prossimità di un buco nero
quindi insomma non stiamo parlando di un
ambiente proprio ospitale in cui sarebbe
piacevole vivere
insieme a questi raggi gamma poi che ci
consentono di andare quindi a studiare
l'universo alle energie più alte in
gioco Vengono prodotti altri messaggeri
Ebbene sì Lo spettro elettromagnetico in
tutte le sue frequenze non è tutto
non ci consente di avere una visione
d'insieme del nostro universo è
necessario considerare qualche altro
protagonista
quali sono questi altri protagonisti
non ce la faccio
Ok abbiamo in primis i raggi cosmici
attenzione
raggi cosmici che sono diversi dai raggi
gamma i raggi gamma di cui abbiamo
parlato prima sono solo una
componente dello spettro
elettromagnetico i raggi cosmici invece
sono particelle di materia
prevalentemente protoni ma anche altri
nuclei leggeri elettroni che vengono
accelerati raggiungono energie
elevatissime e velocità prossime a
quelle della luce e arrivano fino a noi
per fortuna la nostra atmosfera ci
protegge da questi protoni perché
altrimenti la vita come Noi la
conosciamo oggi probabilmente non
esisterebbe questi protoni però
producono altre particelle un altro
Messaggero come lo chiamiamo noi
astrofisici I neutrini
A differenza dei protoni e degli altri
raggi cosmici che sono particelle
cariche I neutrini sono particelle
neutra e hanno Massa piccolissima questo
li rende estremamente difficili da
rivelare da osservare
accanto poi a questi Messaggeri ne viene
prodotto un altro che probabilmente
qualcuno di voi avrà sentito di cui
probabilmente qualcuno di voi avrà
sentito parlare negli ultimi anni perché
ha fatto molto scalpore questo
Messaggero era stato teorizzato
all'inizio del 1900 da Einstein ed è
stato osservato per la prima volta nel
sono le onde gravitazionali delle
perturbazioni dello spazio tempo
generate quando due oggetti molto
massicci dopo aver a lungo abitato una
attorno all'altro si fondono quanto
massicci questi oggetti Beh immaginate
di prendere tutta la terra tutta la
massa della terra e comprimerla in un
oggetto piccolo quanto una biglia
quando questi oggetti si uniscono si
fondono viene prodotta una perturbazione
una oscillazione che arriva fino a noi
oggi siamo in grado di misurare queste
piccole oscillazioni che sono più
piccole della dimensione dei nuclei
atomici e capire da dove sono arrivate
queste onde gravitazionali come vi ho
detto nel 2015 abbiamo osservato per la
prima volta le onde gravitazionali da
allora ne abbiamo osservate molte altre
ma nel 2017 c'è stato un evento molto
importante perché insieme alle onde
gravitazionali per la prima volta nello
stesso momento dallo stesso punto del
cielo abbiamo osservato un lampo di
raggi gamma una radiazione improvvisa
dello spettro elettromagnetico
questo evento che per la prima volta
mette insieme non uno ma due Messaggeri
le onde gravitazionali è la radiazione
elettromagnetica ha dato vita a quella
che oggi viene chiamata astrofisica
multi messaggera
ma c'è un altro evento di cui voglio
parlare mettiamo per un attimo da parte
le onde gravitazionali torniamo Ai raggi
cosmici di cui abbiamo parlato prima
vi ho detto che questi raggi cosmici
sono estremamente energetici Ma noi non
sappiamo dove vengono prodotti Oddio
qualche idea ce le eravamo fatta però
non ne avevamo la conferma
il problema dei raggi cosmici è che non
è possibile quando arriva un raggio
cosmico sulla terra quando ne vediamo
uno andare a osservare in quella regione
del cielo e vedere che cosa c'è
perché questo fatto perché i raggi
cosmici vi ho detto sono particelle
cariche Fra lo spazio interstellare
quello che c'è fra noi e il punto in cui
questi raggi cosmici Vengono prodotti e
portate ad energie estrema Ci sono campi
magnetici molto intensi e quello che
succede quando una particella carica
attraversa un campo magnetico e che
questa viene deviata ora questi raggi
cosmici vengono deviati tantissime volte
fra il momento in cui sono partiti è il
momento in cui noi li osserviamo il che
significa che non è possibile andare a
tracciare a vedere la direzione da cui
sono arrivati semplicemente perché non
la possiamo sapere
questo non si verifica per I neutrini
che vi ho detto vengono prodotti insieme
ai raggi cosmici ma I neutrini sono
estremamente difficili da osservare il
che rende il puzzle ancora più
complicato Ebbene sempre nel 2017 appena
un mese dopo quell'evento in cui abbiamo
osservato insieme onde gravitazionali e
radiazione elettromagnetica è arrivato
un neutrino di origine astrofisica
immediatamente tutta una rete di
telescopi satelliti che osservavano il
cielo nella radiazione elettromagnetica
sono andati a puntare in questa
direzione da cui era arrivato il
neutrino per andare a vedere ma da qui
c'è qualcosa che noi già conosciamo c'è
una sorgente come le chiamiamo noi
astrofisici che noi conosciamo già
ebbene la risposta è stata affermativa
dalla regione del cielo da cui era
arrivato quel neutrino Noi siamo noi
abbiamo trovato una sorgente una
galassia molto lontana da noi al cui
centro c'è un buco nero questo buco nero
ingurgita continuamente la materia della
galassia circoli che lo circonda e nel
fare questo vengono espulsi due oggetti
di materia a velocità prossime a quelle
della luce
Ebbene da questi oggetti noi avevamo già
osservato radiazione elettromagnetica
sapevamo già che in questi ambienti così
estremi viene prodotta radiazione
elettromagnetica radiazione
elettromagnetica Ma la vera osservato
per la prima volta un neutrino prodotto
in queste in questa regione del cielo in
questa sorgente ci ha dato la conferma
che anche i protoni anche i raggi
cosmici Vengono prodotti in questi
ambienti
questo evento insieme all'altro di cui
vi ho parlato prima la rivelazione di
onde gravitazionali ed elettromagnetiche
insieme
ci accompagnano in quella che è la nuova
era dell'astrofisica l'era
dell'astrofisica multi messaggera un'era
che stiamo costruendo proprio in questo
momento perché siamo continuamente
sviluppando nuovi dispositivi per andare
a osservare il cielo a tutte le
frequenze e con tutti i Messaggeri che
l'universo utilizza per comunicare con
noi
per andare a capire quali sono i
fenomeni alla base del nostro universo e
quali sono le leggi che lo regolano
[Applauso]